de cappuccino de magré suiv un curry de
lapins et un
rizuto j'ai beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
je savais rien faire du coup je sais
faire la pâtisserie je suis calé aux
entrées je suis calé au chaud la CHF des
fois me laisse diriger la cuisine avant
c'était cellule promenade cellule
promenade rien d'autre quoi que ça
c'était une pr le matin et pas
l'après-midi donc c'était très très très
très long et là du coup ça a tout changé
je travaille du coup j'arrive à avoir
des permes à l'extérieur on fait on fait
on fait confiance ben moi maintenant mon
objectif c'est la cuisine
quoi chef
une sardine un
cappuccino ça
attendends c'est
essentiel parce que ça leur ça leur
permet de se projeter sur l'extérieur
dire qu'est-ce que je vais faire dehors
comment je peux imaginer un autre
parcours après la déenstion et les
relations qui se cré ici ou les échanges
qui naissent en fait entre les clients
et nos serveurs ou en tout cas toute
notre brigade c'est essentiel pour être
motivé pour regagner un peu de de
confiance en soi et avoir une autre
image de soi-même
ok on va venir h venir juste détailler
comme ça si il beaucoup de juges
d'avocats de donc il y a tout le monde
judicière en fait ici ouais hier on
avait les préfets de police avec 40
policiers qui sont venus manger quoi
donc c'est et ça te fait même bizarre un
peu ouais c'était pas moment d'avant
mais maintenant voilà il faut il faut
évoluer donc c'est une chance qu'on
donne il faut saisir
quoi moi j'ai commencé depuis
l'ouverture les premières équipes nous
ont beaucoup testé ils ont bien compris
que on était là pour eux pour les aider
pour leur trouver du travail un logement
les réinsérer dans la
vie
allez en fait ça va mesurer le métal sur
vous
dans un restaurant de réinsertion un
restaurant où on aide les gens on sent
qu'on fait quelque chose de bien et en
même temps on mange bien j'ai trouvé que
c'était assz intéressant comme réflexion
on a passé un bon moment on
discute petit plus c'est qu'il y a pas
de téléphone donc on a pas le téléphone
sur la
table
pour le moral psychologiquement c'est
bien franchement de voir des gens
deextérieur venir on échange on discute
un peu de notre incarcération comment ça
se passe à l'intérieur au restaurant
avec des tenues ça se passe bien pendant
quelques heure que je suis là je me sens
comme si j'étais à l'extérieur mais
quand je sortir je vais reprendre mon
activité que je faisais dans la
restauration
rapide